alors ce document est une photo prise
par jean paul joe cole qui est un
photographe qui est arrivé à la réunion
dans les années
1949 il travaillait pour le jir dont la
première parution a eu en 1951 le
reportage de monsieur cole constitue un
important témoignage sur la vie à la
région pour les années entre 1950 1970
alors cette photo fait partie d'un
reportage réalisé le 7 octobre 1953 le
général de gaulle effectué alors sa
première visite à la réunion
même s'il vit à cette époque une
traversée du désert politique le
fondateur du rassemblement du peuple
français est encore auréolé du prestige
de son rôle à la libération
et le préfet a reçu pour consigne de
l'accueillir avec des honneurs dus à un
ancien chef d'état
d'ailleurs les réunionnais lui font un
accueil triomphal et le général de
gaulle s'en souviendra et reviendra six
ans plus tard en 1959
quelques mois après son élection à la
présidence de la république